this morning we don't know who's running
the Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
on Friday President Trump named his
budget director Mick Mulvaney to take
over from Richard Cordray Cordray had
announced that deputy director Leandre
English would replace him
well she filed a lawsuit last night to
block the president's choice and now a
judge may have to break the deadlock Jan
Crawford is following the politics of
this unfolding drama Jan good morning
well good morning so the White House
says that Mulvaney is gonna show up to
work at the CFPB today but eglish who
believes she should be the director is
also expected to be there the White
House says she'll be acting only as
Mulvaney's deputy it's a watchdog agency
Wall Street hates it like the devil
hates holy water Democrats are calling
foul the president Trump announced he
wants his budget director to lead the
Consumer Financial Protection Bureau
Mick Mulvaney has been an outspoken
critic of the agency it turns up being a
joke and that's what the CFPB really has
been in a sick sad kind of way
the CFPB was created in the wake of the
2008 financial crisis first proposed by
now senator Elizabeth Warren when she
was a professor at Harvard the idea was
to protect consumers with an independent
watchdog over financial institutions I
think the problem is that the Wall
Street banks really don't like the CFPB
and they have about 12 billion reasons
not to like it since 2011 the Bureau has
provided nearly 12 billion dollars in
relief including billions in refunds to
consumers harmed by illegal banking
practices last year it levied a 100
million dollar fine against Wells Fargo
for opening millions of credit card and
bank accounts possibly without customer
knowledge but some Republican critics
say among other complaints that
regulations have made it harder for
Americans to get approved for credit the
President Trump called the CFPB a total
disaster
last night after English's lawsuit was
filed Republican Senator Tom cotton who
serves on the Senate Banking Committee
reportedly called the bureau a rogue
unconstitutional agency adding the
president should fire her immediately
now late last night and a memo obtained
by CBS News the CFPB's top lawyer agreed
with the White House that President
Trump does have authority to name his
own acting director Gail all right a lot
of us are watching this story thank you
very much Jann